en pâtisserie comme en art il faut faire
preuve de créativité et pour réaliser sa
sculpture mais li na l'a bien compris
une oeuvre constituée de 50 kg de
chocolat ont fait une structure en
chocolat pour les portes ouvertes à
l'inauguration du nouveau lycée car il a
été fait récemment
et donc on a choisi de travailler sur la
musique et la nature donc on a mélangé
un arbre avec une guitare on l'a
dessinée et après
la coulée du chocolat pour faire la base
de structures et on l'a collé en
polystyrène qu'on a pas
avec du chocolat une pièce qui ne sera
pas déguster mais exposer un défi pour
cette jeune pâtissière qui a déjà
l'habitude de se surpasser
mélina participer au championnat ile de
france du dessert
elle est arrivée deuxième de la
catégorie junior c'était d entraînement
très intense des gens de très longues
donc on est quand même contents de la
position qu'on a eu sinon c'était une
bonne expérience dans l'ensemble ça
apprend aussi à avoir d'autres choses
parce qu'on a pu voir aussi les
professionnels travailler c'est un
excellent résultat excellent et de
tâches très très content et s'est
investi à fond voilà prêt à lâcher donc
c'est très très bien a sorti un dessert
propre dans les temps ce n'est investie
intéressés et motivés
une motivation qui lui a servi pour
terminer sa création après plusieurs
mois de travail résultats dévoilés lors
des journées portes ouvertes de
l'établissement l'a collé quelques
éléments comme des feuilles quelques
fleurs pour pour égayer le tout est
ramené un peu de brillance encore
quelques détails à peaufiner mais les
visiteurs sont déjà conquis c'est un
beau travail et puis justement
s'interroger sur la technique qui avait
derrière parce que ça représente ada
parce que la jeune fille mais expliqué
50 kg de chocolat sa passion mélina m la
partager c'est avec son grand père
qu'elle réalise souvent des desserts
pour la famille aujourd'hui paris brest
revisité qu'est ce que tu fais un très
bon ça se faire par la tienne j'aime
bien tout ce qui est sucré un peu
gourmand et puis donc sotuba de médina
qui était à mes côtés m'apporte beaucoup
d'information technique pour la
réalisation différents mais cette
recette de philippe conticini possède un
coeur coulant au praliné
un bon moyen pour s'entraîner même après
six ans passés au lycée hôtelier
après sa scolarité mélina aimerait
intégrer un grand restaurant il ya plus
de travail dans l'assiette plus de
finition et puis il ya il ya des petits
les petits coups de feu en cuisine
du coup ça donne plus de plus
d'adrénaline donc je pense que ça sera
plus ce milieu là un milieu qu'elle se
dit prête à rejoindre ne manque plus
qu'à passer son diplôme à la fin de
l'année